il ya des éléments en effet qu'ils sont
très étonnant pourquoi cette épidémie
dépeint ryan alors que c'est un des f1
cr des trois centres mondiaux de
recherche et d'expérimentation sans
doute un peu dangereux sur l'écran d'un
virus donc on peut se poser la question
mais non enfin personnellement dans une
analyse et propagande je dirais pas que
c'est un jouer un rôle majeur puisqu'il
n'y a pas de preuves qui ont été
apportées 1 puisque les travaux
scientifiques depuis un an montrent que
ça peut être naturel quand on regarde le
détail du virus on ne voit pas quelque
chose qui fait dire non ça ça peut pas
être ça peut pas être naturel ya eu des
hypothèses comme ça au début on se
rappelle certains handicapés des
morceaux de sida dedans et ça c'était
les théories complètement loufoque
elle s'était donc ettori d'une fuite de
laboratoire loufoque mais ya des torts
et de fuite de laboratoire qui ne sont
pas loufoque
est ce que le virus il a existé de
telquel collectés dans la nature et puis
se seraient échappées voir est ce qu'il
ya eu des manipulations de qu'on appelle
de gains de fonction pour le rendre plus
dangereux puisque ça se faisait aussi à
va donc tout ça fait qu'on peut être
soupçonneux de dogan au début mais
simplement dans un deuxième temps
il n'y a pas eu de preuve l'allemand la
chine a nié et c'est très compliqué de
prouver que le virus est sorti de la
bouée n'est pas n'est pas naturel quant
à la partie propagande bat évidemment ce
qui a changé c'est le président des
états unis
c'est ça qui est très important quand on
écoute les médias aujourd'hui on
al'impression c'était interdit de dire
que la fille du labo aurait été possible
c'était la position de donald trump la
puissance américaine pendant tout 2020
car dès le mois de mai a expliqué qu'ils
avaient même épreuve que c'était sortie
de l'abonné dont j'avais montré en en
faisant un peu un discours à la armes de
destruction massive en irak
le 15 janvier 2021 ils ont de nouveau
dit la même chose donc c'était trempe
les médias n'ont pas suivi mais par
contre dès que ben laden est arrivé
l'administration n'a strictement pas
changé toujours dit ben on sait pas si
c'est naturel et on sait pas si c'est
sorti d'un labo et c'est vrai qu'on
n'est pas sûr à son bon sens mais là les
médias ont tout de suite embrayé sur la
position américaine donc ce qui est très
amusant c'est que les médias d'habitude
suivent la propagande du gouvernement
américain de façon très très très
militaire presque mais là comme s'était
trump et comme il y avait eu des
théories vraiment absurde au début de
complot depuis du laboratoire un peu
délirante
les médias n'avaient pas suivi donc
c'est très intéressant parce qu'on a un
jeu de propagande contre propagande et
propagande anti chinoises contre buy
propagande chinoise qui peut-être mais
peut-être ne ment pas on ne sait pas et
il est très difficile d'y voir clair
[Musique]